hi I'm Erik Bosse and the ventures the
end games biggest mystery might be what
exactly do they mean by in-game past
titles of Avengers movies have been
fairly straightforward infinity war was
about a war for infinity things
age of Ultron was about Ultron in an age
that lasted a few days
endgame is one of those words that has a
clear meaning but it doesn't immediately
answer the question like the term has
been spoken out loud a few times before
but why exactly did the filmmakers
choose the word in-game was it just the
generic meeting or the chest meaning or
is there some deeper meaning that we're
overlooking spoiler warning again a my
predictions end up being right and ruin
your life let's start with the basic
definition of end game and game which
can be used as one word or two words
refers to that final phase of chess in
which both sides begin making strategic
sacrifices of valuable pieces in order
to corner their opponent's king to
checkmate and game is also taken on a
broader meaning to describe the final
stage of any conflict or trial or
contest like a war a duel an election so
when we saw the title was Avengers
endgame I think that's how most people
interpreted it it's the Avengers final
charge and their war against Thanos but
the good news is it means the worrying
over there's still an end game perhaps
the same endgame that Doctor Strange
alluded to in the final act of infinity
war why aren't you doing we're in the
endgame yeah but this term was also used
by Tony Stark in age of Ultron to
justify to his fellow Avengers why he
initially thought the world needed
Ultron we can bust arms to us on the
live long day but that up there that's
that's the a game so I would be a little
surprised if endgame was just referring
to the straightforward surface level
meaning of a final assault so what else
could it mean
well in-game has appeared as a title in
a number of Marvel Comics The Incredible
Hulk has an issue titled and game
there's an x factor series called
endgame and game is also the name of one
of legions many personalities inside of
him Avengers 71 is a story called
endgame that was from the 60s it
featured the Avengers fighting the
time-traveling villain Kang the
Conqueror with three of the avengers
sent back to the year 1941 to fight the
Marvel
of that era there's another Iron Man
comic issue 165 called endgame which
featured chess themed villains and
broody in a deathtrap
then there was Stannis number six that
was called endgame and actually featured
Thanos says sort of an antihero
restoring planets and combating hunger
and branching out from Marvel Comics the
term endgame has shown up all across the
media there's actually the title of a
Samuel Beckett play about characters in
the aftermath of an apocalyptic event I
think it is possible that the movie
Avengers endgame could draw certain
story elements from all these sources
like obviously a post-apocalyptic
setting but also time travel chests
Thanos says a protagonist but I just
don't think that the Russo brothers are
gonna come out and mention any of these
specific things as direct inspirations
for the film I'm a question for Joe and
Anthony Russo what was your inspiration
for this movie we got the idea for
endgame from the comic book endgame next
question
yeah I think it's better to judge the
direction of the Avengers movies by the
overall trajectory of the past films in
this connection between the title of
this movie being Avengers endgame Doctor
Strange saying the term endgame and Tony
Stark saying the term endgame it all
looks very clear to me a very direct
line it doesn't feel accidental or
incidental in fact it's almost as if by
telling Tony Stark we're in the endgame
now Doctor Strange could have
intentionally used the word stark used
before like he knew what he was doing
but strange wasn't there for that
conversation an EI mine readers so how
could he know that well I think it's
worth revisiting the relationship
between Doctor Strange and Tony Stark
however brief it was and we know what
the term endgame initially meant to Tony
Stark let's actually rewatch Tony's
in-game moment from age of Ultron and
widen out the context of it remember
when I carried a nuke through a wormhole
no never come save New York never heard
that recall that hostile alien army came
charging through a hole in space we're
staying at 300 feet below it worthy
Avengers we can bust arms dealers all
the live long day but that up there
that's that's the a game the end game
for Tony is the cosmic threat that he's
been preparing for in his nightmares
ever since that moment you can actually
see it in his eyes when banners strange
and Wong warned him about the Ennis at
the beginning of infinity war attack on
New York that's him this is serious game
laterz start confirms this haunting by
the threat of Danis directly the
strangest phase the eros has been inside
my head for six years since he sent an
army to New York and now he's back so
I'm not so sure if it's a better plan if
I don't want a heart or for his dole I
say we take the fight to him so Doctor
Strange knew that Tony Stark had endgame
on the mine as a fellow genius perhaps
strand respected Tony Stark's
calculating brain and later in the movie
when strange looks forward and time at
all the millions of different possible
future outcomes I think one of those
futures could have taken place in the
past how could this be possible before I
get to that thank you to privacy comm
for sponsoring this video
privacy comm allows you to avoid the
risk of credit card fraud when you're
paying for things online giving you a
brand new virtual card number for every
purchase you make instead of giving the
merchant your real debit or credit card
number like sure some of them seem
trustworthy but you never really know
right like they could get hacked or they
could be one of the shady places out
there that sells your data to third
parties or I don't know you could have
basically just handed a blank check to a
random stranger named Leon who's on his
last day of the job and can't wait to
charge you six hundred bucks or energy
drinks Leon plans to live forever and
though you have to deal with Leon look
I'm tired of worrying about this stuff
so check out I downloaded the privacy
browser extension signed up and they use
privacy to create a card specifically
for my monthly Netflix subscription
payment it's super easy I linked it to
my bank account not showing you that
Leon's and for this virtual card I'm
setting the limit just above my $13.99
monthly subscription payment so it's
like worst case scenario someone tries
to use this privacy card number again
we're like overcharge it privacy will
notify me that they blocked it because
the spending limit was already reached
see it's simple it's fast it's really
just like one click and just so you know
this service is free
privacy makes its money from the
merchants not from you they don't sell
your information they have a military
level encryption so you don't have to
worry about them getting hacked it's
really a no-brainer folks in for a
limited time first time customers who
sign up with privacy calm / new rock
stars will get five dollars off their
first purchase with privacy calm folks
they're giving you money to help you
stay safe during your holiday shopping
so get on this go to privacy calm / new
rock star
that's PRI DAC why.com /in e w ro c KS t
AR s to get $5 off your first purchase
now
okay back to dr. Strange's plan how
could one of his visions of the future
actually be set in the past well I kind
of did go into this my recent ant-man
time-travel video go check it out yes
all of our videos are ads for other
videos we've done but here's a Jess
strange could have theoretically found
out that time travel without the time
stone is possible if a past version of
Scott Lang came knocking on his door
it's got lying who would have gotten
through time vortex is down in the
quantum realm and perhaps the vision
that dr. strange saw of the one future
outcome in which they were victorious
featured one of a few conditions in
which the Avengers use time vortexes
that ant-man went through in the quantum
realm to travel back in time to key
moments from past Marvel films that can
explain all these leaks set rumors of
actors and old costumes for past films
restaging certain scenes from the first
Avengers movie and characters who were
supposed to be dead somehow coming back
and maybe one of those past moments that
dr. strange saw and his future could
have been that seen an age of Ultron
when Tony was ranting about end games
and so when dr. strange told Tony Stark
we're in the end game now it was code
maybe he was deliberately trying to
trigger that memory for Stark to tell
him remember that moment go back to that
moment what else did you say when he
said endgame let's look again we can
bust arms dealers all the live long day
but that up there that's that's the
again how are you guys planning on
beating that together we'll lose and
we'll do that together too AHA see
strange is telling Stark that he needs
to rejoin his old friend me Captain
America and that together the two of
them need to lose they need to sacrifice
themselves and that brings us back to
the concept of endgame in chess that
final stage which you make key
sacrifices to get to the checkmate maybe
for me the reason these two men Tony
Stark Stephen strange seems so parallel
is that for both Robert Downey jr.
Benedict Cumberbatch there's second most
famous role is the same fictional
character they both played recent
iterations of Sherlock Holmes
Cumberbatch in the BBC show party Jay in
the Guy Ritchie movies and the second
Ritchie movie is titled a game of
shadows that title worth
to the memorable scene the movie a chess
match between Holmes and Moriarty
there's sacrificing of pieces parallels
the movement of their foot soldiers
inside with Watson trying to smooth out
Moriarty's hidden assassin eventually
the two geniuses move this endgame from
the chessboard to a chessboard in their
minds they start calling out moves to
each other verbally it's awesome and we
watching it I think I discovered another
reason strange might have made a chess
reference to stark chess is a game of
time after each move you literally punch
a clock so like the end game of the game
of chess Avengers in game could feature
heroes punching a clock between each of
their moves using time travel devices to
jump back again and again to strategic
points in time make a series of
calculated sacrifices perhaps forcing
each of these six Avengers to die one by
one
to prevent Thanos from acquiring each of
the six Infinity stones one by one and
then gradually corner the mad Titan into
checkmate comment down below with
waiting you think endgame could mean
fall new rock stars on twitter at new
rockstars follow me on twitter and
instagram @ ee vos subscribe to new rock
stars for theories predictions updates
of all kinds about avengers endgame
which could be just themed how fun is
that it has literally never been done
for a fantasy movie checkmate
oh yeah
[Music]